at this point with her bags packed and
her family killed Pearl has bet
everything on the dance audition there
is no plan B she even lets this slip in
front of mity has to be
me I don't think you meant to say that
out loud
Pearl well if it's not me then I hope
you
right has to be me while Pearl is
focused and deadly serious almost like
an athlete in a freegame ritual mity is
nervous and begs Pearl to switch places
with her she obliges and mity thanks her
telling her that she's a good friend
Emma of course you are sister-in-laws
have to stick together right this
demonstrates again that Pearl feels
things deeply gets super attached and is
hyper aware of how people see her she
ultimately just wants to be loved and
appreciated something she never got from
her